URS HOLZLE: We've all
heard about Snapchat.
A small team of
engineers that have
built one of the most
popular applications
on the internet today.
And it's been fun for
us to partner with them.
And so I'm excited today
to welcome Bob Murphy, CTO,
and co-founder of
Snapchat to the stage
so we can hear their
story first hand.
Sorry, Bobby.
Please come up.
[APPLAUSE]
BOBBY MURPHY: Hello.
URS HOLZLE: Bobby,
glad meeting you.
All right, so I'm curious
how you actually got
started with both the idea,
and sort of the infrastructure.
What led you there?
BOBBY MURPHY: Yeah.
So Evan and I got started
on Snapchat summer of 2011.
Basically, kind of understood
that visual content
was the most engaging,
interesting form of content
that there was.
And wanted to create
a way to enable
that to be a means
of communication,
rather than a piece of content
around which communication
actually happened.
So that was sort of the initial
concept behind Snapchat.
We launched on Google
App Engine because I'd
used App Engine a couple
times for some small projects,
found it was super easy
to get up and running.
And at the time, obviously,
our biggest priority
was to get a product
in the hands of users
in the world-- in the real
world-- as quickly as possible.
And so I turned again
to App Engine, something
I was very familiar with.
And a platform that very
easily abstracts away
a lot of the complexities of
building, deploying, and a web
backend into the real world.
And I think at the
time, App Engine
was actually still
in preview, so we
took a chance on a new platform.
But I was fairly
confident that given
Google's kind of reputation as
a very strong infrastructure
company, that anything
we built on App Engine
would eventually scale
if we needed it to.
URS HOLZLE: And it did.
BOBBY MURPHY: Yep.
URS HOLZLE: Can you
tell us a little bit
about how the platform
supported your launch of more
recent features, like
the stories feature
that you launched just recently?
BOBBY MURPHY: Yeah, absolutely.
It's actually been
very surprising for us,
and like super fortunate,
to see cloud platform
kind of grow its feature
set almost perfectly in sync
with our own feature needs.
It's actually funny looking
at the timeline earlier,
because we've taken
advantage of almost all
of those product offerings
almost immediately
upon them being released
to the general public.
So around the time that we
were launching stories, which
was fall of last
year, App Engine
was great for our
core application,
but we were looking for
something a little bit
more flexible to support the
stories architecture, which
currently uses Retis on a
huge cluster of Compute Engine
instances.
And so we were
looking around, and it
was exactly when Compute Engine
launched to the general public,
and so along with outgoing
socket connections
from App Engine front end.
So it was actually
perfect timing for us.
That's worked and scaled
tremendously well.
URS HOLZLE: So you're
running lots of Retis today?
BOBBY MURPHY: We are.
Yeah, we've got, I
think, 256 master nodes,
and two slaves per each,
and with a twin proxy
cluster in front,
and Google load
balancers in front of that.
URS HOLZLE: OK.
And so, obviously, that all came
with a huge amount of growth,
right?
Not just in the
beginning, but actually,
it's really an amazing thing,
is that the growth has just
been keeping up.
So how have we helped you?
I hope we have helped you.
BOBBY MURPHY: Yep.
Yeah, you guys have seen
the growth first hand.
Absolutely.
So, I mean, the biggest
benefit is just the fact
that we can focus much less
on maintaining infrastructure,
and much more on building
new infrastructure to support
the features and the product
developments that we need.
In fact, actually, Tim, one
of our VPs of engineering,
just last week told me, one
of his biggest surprises
at joining Snapchat
was at not having
to deal with the operational
headache and complexity
that he was expecting,
and you would
expect from a
company at our growth
rate and our current scale.
So, yeah, the biggest
benefit is just the fact
that we can focus less on
maintaining infrastructure
and much more on
building new stuff.
URS HOLZLE: And so as
far as I understand,
you still don't have an
operations team, really.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BOBBY MURPHY: No, not really.
We're at about 25 engineers
now, and a little bit
of operational work here and
there, but for the most part,
everyone's focused on
new feature development.
URS HOLZLE: Cool.
So if you had a piece
of advice for anyone
out there who wants to build
the next Snapchat on a Google
Platform-- a cloud platform--
how should they go about it?
BOBBY MURPHY: I would just
say it's a super easy platform
to use.
We got started on
App Engine, which
is amazingly simple to use, and
has scaled tremendously well.
I've been absolutely
impressed and very surprised
that it's scaled
as well as it has.
I certainly thought, early on,
the kind of traditional notion
of, you build on
a hosted solution,
and then you reach a certain
size, at which you have
to move off, I think is
fading, and Google's kind
of paving the way there.
And so, what's great
about App Engine,
and cloud platform
in general, is
that you get that kind
of up-front ease of use
with the added comfort of
knowing that whatever you're
building, if it needs to, will
eventually scale ad infinitum.
URS HOLZLE: Great!
Let's go to infinity and beyond.
BOBBY MURPHY: Right.
URS HOLZLE: Thanks, Bobby.
BOBBY MURPHY: Yep.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]